[موسيقى]
الانتخابات القدر ما هي غايه لكن في نفس
الوقت هذه الانتخابات تحتاج الى تهيئه
وتحتاج الى عمل وتحتاج الى اداره يعني
الان نحن للاسف في ليبيا
ناتج عندنا موجوده
تسمى الحكومه وطنيه يجب ان احنا الان
نفكروا في مخرج برعايه امميه برعايه دوليه
برعايه وطنيه هذا ينتج عنها اداره واحده
بحيث هذه الاداره تتمكن من القيام
انتخابات طالما النهار هناك موجود ادارتين
كما لو كان هذا هذه تشتغل بشكل متضاد ولا
انت وصلنا لمرحله الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
هناك مشاكل حقيقيه حدثت يعني مثلا هناك
تزوير فيما يسمى بالرقم الوطني هذا
التصوير تصوير اييه وصل لحوادث 90000
مواطن دخلوا
وسجلوا باحتباره الليبيين وهم ومش ليبيين
السجل المدني في تصريح النائب العام في
اكثر من 65 شخص
65000 شخص وجود انهم جوازات مزوره اكثر من
20 الف جواز
اذن في هذه الحاله علينا لما تكون في
اداره اداره واعيه واداره وطنيه اول خطوه
تديرها تعمل مراجعه لهذه السجلات تعمل
تدقيق حتى سجل الناخبين استاذ
النائب العام يتحدث عن
25000 بطاقه مزوره معناها هناك مشكله اسمه
كان في السجل المدني والله في همم ارقام
الوطنيه الانتخابيه
[موسيقى]